Geht es los?
Ja.
Heute war irgendwas.
Welches Datum war heute?
*Er spricht auf Englisch.*
Heute ist
internationaler "Star Wars"-Day.
Deswegen schauen wir uns
heute den "Orden der Jedi" an.
Gemeinsam mit einem
Religionswissenschaftler
und mit einem echten Jedi.
Die sind nicht mehr nur
in "Star Wars" zu Hause,
auch in unserer realen Welt.
*Titelmusik von "Star Wars"*
Werden Menschen in Großbritannien,
in Australien oder Neuseeland nach
ihrer Religionszugehörigkeit gefragt,
geben zehntausende Menschen an,
Jedi zu sein.
Auch bei uns im deutschsprachigen
Raum steigt die Anzahl der Anhänger.
Ich habe mich gefragt, sind das
nur Hardcore-"Star Wars"-Fans,
die versuchen,
den Film in ihren Alltag zu holen.
Oder sind das spirituelle Menschen,
die ein echtes Glaubensleben
führen wollen.
Um das herauszufinden, bin ich
heute auf der Burg Hessenstein.
Diese Burg wird zu bestimmten Zeiten
im Jahr zu einem Jedi-Tempel,
weil die hier zusammenkommen.
Hier treffe ich heute Max.
Er ist Jedi-Meister und Gründer
des "Order of Jedi" in Deutschland.
Außerdem Dr. Christian Feichtinger.
Er ist Religionswissenschaftler
an der Uni Graz
und ein "Star Wars"-Experte.
Mit beiden checke ich,
was die Jedi aus "Stars Wars"
mit großen Religionen
gemeinsam haben.
Was dieses Jeditum
im Alltag bedeutet,
wie es gelebt wird und
wie ihr selbst Jedi werden könnt.
Yes!
Für so einen Deep Dive
braucht man einen Überblick.
Denn in "Star Wars" erstreckt sich
die Geschichte der Jedi
über tausende von Jahren.
Dafür haben wir uns Jakob vom Kanal
"Star Wars Stories" ins Boot geholt.
Denn im deutschsprachigen Raum
kennt sich niemand so gut aus wie er.
Jakob, wie sind die Jedi
eigentlich entstanden?
Hey, Jack.
Der Orden der Jedi entstand
ca. 25.000 Jahre vor Episode 1.
Damals kam es zu einem Konflikt
zwischen den Anhängern der
hellen und dunklen Seite der Macht.
Die Anhänger der hellen Seite
konnten sich durchsetzen
und gründeten
daraufhin den Jedi-Orden.
Kurze Zeit später gründete sich
die Galaktische Republik.
Daraufhin schlossen sich
die Jedi dieser an
und dienten seit jeher
als Friedenshüter in der Galaxis.
Lange Zeit danach spalteten sich
jedoch dunkle Jedi vom Orden ab
und vermischten ihr Blut
mit dem der Zivilisation der Sith.
Eine uralte Spezies
vom Planeten Korriban.
Über Jahrtausende
versuchten die Sith,
die Kontrolle
über die Galaxis zu erlangen.
Meist mit mehr Rückschlägen
als Erfolgen.
Erst im Zuge der Order 66,
also in Episode III,
sollte es ihnen gelingen, die
Republik und die Jedi zu vernichten.
Bis Luke Skywalker nach Episode VI
einen neuen Jedi-Orden schuf.
Welcher sich dann ebenfalls in den
Dienst der neuen Republik stellte.
Die Jedi haben also der Republik
gedient und ziemlich eingesteckt.
Um zu verstehen,
wie die Jedi denken, fragte ich mich:
Wenn die so mächtig sind,
warum haben die nicht
die ganze Zeit allein geherrscht?
Die Jedi handeln
nach einem strengen Kodex,
der ihnen helfen soll,
im Einklang mit der Macht zu leben.
Der variiert
zwischen dem offiziellen Kanon
und den ergänzenden
Legends-Inhalten.
Wenn man das zusammen betrachtet,
dann schreibt der Kodex vor,
dass die Jedi die Friedenswächter
der Galaxis sind.
Sie dürfen die Macht
nur zur Verteidigung
und zum Schutz anderer verwenden.
Dazu gehört, dass sie
ein Leben ohne privaten Besitz
und in Partnerlosigkeit führen.
Und ihre Stärken aus den 3 Säulen
Disziplin, Wissen und Macht ziehen.
Danke, Jakob.
Die Jedi haben also
ein klares Selbstverständnis.
Wie viel das
mit echter Religion zu tun hat,
das finden wir raus
mit einem Experten von der Uni Graz.
Der kennt sich
in beiden Bereichen aus:
in der Religion und mit "Star Wars".
Christian, toll, dass du da bist.
Jack, schön, hier zu sein.
Du bist Religionswissenschaftler.
Diese Kombination von den Jedi aus
Kodex, Enthaltsamkeit, Beschützertum
klingt für mich wie eine Mischung
aus "Ritter trifft Mönch".
Hat sich George Lucas
das dort abgeschaut?
Auf jeden Fall.
Zuerst denke ich an die Samurai,
die in der Idealvorstellung
dieses Image
des ehrenvollen Kriegers haben.
Die in ihrer Spiritualität
und ihrem Ethos
von japanischem Zen-Buddhismus
geprägt sind.
Wenn man sich
die Jedi-Roben anschaut,
erkennt man die Inspiration
durch japanische Samurai-Filme.
Und was für einen Jedi
unverzichtbar ist,
ist das Lichtschwert.
Auch hier gibt es Parallelen
zum Katana-Schwert der Samurai.
Das war für sie ein Kultgegenstand
und wurde auch
als Seele der Samurai bezeichnet.
Wir sehen auch einige Parallelen
zwischen den heiligen Stätten.
Wir haben den Jedi-Tempel, wo es
Bezüge zu japanischen Heiligtümern
aus dem Shintoismus oder auch
chinesischen heiligen Stätten gibt.
Auch Elemente des Kirchenbaus
sind da zu finden.
Wir sehen auch die Ähnlichkeit des
Rebellenstützpunktes mit Pyramiden.
Von den Äußerlichkeiten
funktioniert das gut.
Robe, Waffen, heilige Stätten.
Wie sieht es mit der Philosophie
der Jedi aus, wo kommt die her?
Auch da hat sich George Lucas stark
bei asiatischen Traditionen bedient.
Das merkt man
beim Konzept der Macht.
Die weist große Ähnlichkeiten auf
mit der Idee des Chi
aus dem chinesischen Daoismus.
Eine Art Lebenskraft,
Lebensenergie, die alles umfasst.
Aus dem Daoimus stammt
auch das bekannte Yin-Yang-Symbol,
die Gegensätzlichkeit,
das Weiße und das Schwarze.
Die sind aber nicht
komplett getrennt.
Das eine enthält immer
den Keim des anderen.
So ist es auch mit der hellen
und der dunklen Seite der Macht.
Interessant
ist die sehr enge Verbindung
von Spiritualität
und Meditation einerseits
und Kampfbereitschaft andererseits.
Die finden wir auch im Buddhismus
bei den Shaolin-Mönchen.
Die haben
in ihrer spirituellen Praxis
Bewegungsmeditation
und geistige Übungen.
Die sind verbunden
mit körperlichem Training
und dem Erlernen von Kampfkünsten.
Um sich selbst, ihren Orden und
ihre Heimat verteidigen zu können.
Wir haben viel
über asiatische Religion gesprochen.
Aber George Lucas wuchs in einer
christlichen Methodistenkirche auf,
einer speziellen Form
der Evangelischen Kirche.
Da wird es sicher
auch Einflüsse gegeben haben?
Ja, wir sind hier in einer Burg.
Wenn man in die christliche
Geschichte zurückblickt,
sehen wir hier auch eine Verbindung
von Spiritualität und Kampfkraft.
Nämlich bei den Tempelrittern.
Viel offensichtlicher
ist der bekannte Jedi-Gruß:
Was sich direkt ableitet
vom christlichen Segensspruch:
Im Christentum haben wir,
wie auch bei den Jedi,
Lebensprinzipien.
Eine Art Regelwerk, an dem
man sein Leben ausrichten soll.
Allerdings, und das ist
ein wichtiger Unterschied:
Im Christentum
werden die Prinzipien
von einem persönlichen Gott
vorgegeben.
Bei den Jedi haben wir
keine Vorstellung von einem Gott.
Deswegen sind die 10 Gebote
viel genauer und direktiver.
Während der Jedi-Kodex viel mehr
Interpretations-Spielraum zulässt.
Das stimmt, bei den 10 Geboten
ist es sehr zielgerichtet:
Du sollst nicht töten.
Im Jedi-Kodex steht nur:
Es gibt keinen Tod,
es gibt nur die Macht.
Genau, solche Regelwerke
und Gruß- und Segensformen
haben wir auch
in allen anderen Religionen.
Aber wenn man sich
so Themen anschaut
wie Versuchung, Schuld,
Reue, Vergebung, Erlösung:
Da merkt man klar
den christlichen Einfluss
auf "Star Wars".
Natürlich auch
bei moralischen Idealen
wie Selbstlosigkeit,
Bescheidenheit oder Gerechtigkeit.
Aber auch das finden wir ähnlich,
auch in verschiedenen Religionen.
Weil die Religionen,
und auch "Star Wars",
vor den Versuchungen warnen, die
für den Menschen gefährlich sind.
Also Egoismus, Neid, Zorn,
Machtmissbrauch oder Gier.
Genau den Dingen,
denen Anakin Skywalker verfällt
und die ihn vom Jedi
zum Sith-Lord werden lassen.
*Er spricht auf Englisch.*
*dramatische Musik*
*Anakin Skywalker
spricht auf Englisch.*
Wo wir bei Anakin Skywalker sind:
Auch hier sehen wir
ein wichtiges religiöses Motiv,
die Hoffnung auf einen Messias.
Denn auch die Jedi
haben eine Prophezeiung,
dass ein Erlöser kommen wird.
Der das Gleichgewicht der Macht
wieder herstellen wird.
Und in "Star Wars" ist das
Anakin Skywalker oder Darth Vader.
Während im Christentum
die Erlöserfigur Jesus Christus ist.
Okay, das ist schon
ein heftiger Vergleich.
Darth Vader
ist gleich Jesus Christus.
Wenn man sich
das Leben von Jesus anguckt:
Er kommt in der Bibel
deutlich netter und besser weg
als Darth Vader im Film.
*spannende Musik*
*Schreien*
*Krachen*
Darth Vader
war wirklich kein Heiliger.
Im Unterschied zu Jesus hat er
der Versuchung durch das Böse
nicht widerstanden.
Aber sowohl am Anfang
als auch am Ende ihres Lebens
gibt es Parallelen.
Beide werden jungfräulich empfangen,
was auf ihren Sonderstatus hinweist.
Am Ende vollbringen beide
ihr Erlösungswerk dadurch,
dass sie sich selbst opfern.
Jesus für die Menschheit
und Anakin für seinen Sohn Luke.
I won't leave you.
*ruhige Musik*
Jesus stirbt,
dann kommt die Auferstehung,
dann fährt er auf in den Himmel.
Christen haben eine klare Vorstellung
vom Himmel und von der Hölle.
Das haben wir bei den Jedi nicht.
Wie läuft es bei denen?
Da kommen wir mehr
zu den asiatischen Einflüssen
bei George Lucas.
Die Jedi werden
nach dem Tod verbrannt
und kehren in die Macht zurück
oder gehen in der Macht auf.
Aber sie lernen später, in der Macht
ihre Individualität beizubehalten
und als Geistwesen
weiter zu existieren.
Und als Geistwesen
in der Welt weiter zu wirken.
Das ist vergleichbar
mit den "Bodhisattvas",
mit den Erleuchtungswesen in einer
bestimmten Form des Buddhismus.
Wir haben Ähnliches
auch im japanischen Shintoismus.
Da finden wir die Kami,
Gottheiten oder Geistwesen,
die auf die Menschen
Einfluss nehmen können.
Die auch als Botschafter
des Überirdischen fungieren.
Ähnlich agieren auch die Jedi
als Geistwesen in "Stars Wars",
nehmen Einfluss auf die Lebenden.
Z.B. bei Rey
im letzten "Stars Wars"-Film.
*Er spricht auf Englisch.*
Fassen wir zusammen.
George Lucas wuchs in der
christlichen Methodistenkirche auf.
Den christlichen Einfluss
sehen wir in den "Star Wars"-Filmen.
Genauso wichtig
ist die asiatische Spiritualität.
Bestimmte Formen wie z.B.
Buddhismus, Shintoismus und Daoismus.
Genau.
Eine Sache fehlt noch,
die kaum bekannt ist.
In den 1970er-Jahren
gibt es einen Mann
namens Carlos Castaneda.
Er schreibt eine ganze Reihe Bücher.
Der Held seiner Bücher ist
Don Juan Matus, ein alter Weiser,
der seine Energie aus der
geheimnisvollen Kraft bezieht.
Der dort den Protagonisten in
die Geheimnisse der Kraft einweiht.
Das Ganze
stammt aus der damaligen Esoterik,
aus der New Age-Literatur.
Hier nimmt Lucas starke Anleihen.
Sowohl
in seinem Verständnis der Macht
als auch in seiner Gestaltung
der Figur des Yoda.
Der diesem Don Joan Matus
nachempfunden ist.
Yes!
Das ist ja total irre.
Das ist ein wilder Mix von vielen
religiösen Motiven und Strömungen.
Ist es beabsichtigt,
dass George Lucas
das alles zusammengehauen hat?
Ja, wobei es ihm nicht darum ging,
das irgendwie wild zu mischen.
Seine eigentliche Motivation
stammt aus der Überzeugung:
Dass seiner Ansicht nach
alle Religionen
einen gemeinsamen Kern haben.
Eine gemeinsame Grundspiritualität,
die sie miteinander verbindet.
Deswegen war es
für ihn kein Problem,
diese verschiedenen
Religionen zu mischen.
Worum es ihm eigentlich ging,
ist, darauf hinzuweisen,
dass es etwas Höheres gibt,
ein Mehr gibt im Leben.
Und dass es
für den Menschen nicht egal ist,
dass es dieses Mehr,
dieses Höhere gibt.
Sondern dass er sich
damit befassen muss.
Das sieht man gerade bei den Jedi.
Die leben in einer
hochtechnologischen Welt.
Die sind verstrickt in politische
und gesellschaftliche Konflikte.
Aber ihr Schicksal hängt davon ab,
wie sehr es ihnen gelingt,
mit diesem Höheren
in Verbindung zu bleiben.
Das war die zentrale Message
von George Lucas.
Wie geht es euch denn?
Habt ihr noch andere Szenen, Motive
oder evtl. auch Gegenstände entdeckt,
die ihr aus den "Star Wars"-Filmen
in Verbindung mit Religionen bringt?
Das Universum ist groß.
Wenn ihr da was gefunden habt,
lasst gern einen Kommentar dazu da.
Die Jedi sind also offensichtlich
von mehreren Religionen beeinflusst.
Diese Mischung
ist eigentlich fiktional.
Sie ist offenbar
für so viele Menschen inspirierend,
dass sie angeben,
nach dem Jediismus zu leben.
Sie geben also
bei Volkszählungen oder Umfragen an,
dass das ihre Religion ist.
Da weiß man nicht,
wie viele davon echte Gläubige sind
und wie viele nur
aus Protest das hinschreiben.
Im Detail lässt sich das
aus den Zensus-Zahlen nicht ablesen.
Offiziell anerkannt ist die Religion
der Jedi noch in keinem Land.
Bei uns in Deutschland
ist das sowieso anders.
Denn hier gibt es das Jeditum.
Bei dem die Menschen nicht unbedingt
an die Macht glauben müssen,
sondern vielmehr nach den Regeln und
dem Selbstverständnis der Jedi leben.
Es gibt hier mehrere Orden,
in denen man sich zum Jedi-Ritter
ausbilden lassen kann.
Wie das aussieht, das wird mir
gleich ein echter Jedi erklären.
Vorher will ich von Jakob wissen:
Wie sieht die Jedi-Ausbildung
in den Filmen aus?
Die Jünglinge bzw. Jedi-Anwärter
werden mit 6 Jahren
oder jünger auserwählt
und in den Lehren der Macht sowie
des Schwertkampfes unterwiesen.
D.h., sie lernen,
ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen,
die Macht zu beeinflussen.
Sowie die Grundlagen
des Lichtschwertkampfes.
Ab dem 13. Lebensjahr beginnen sie
dann ihre Ausbildung als Padawan.
Indem sie einen schon fertig
ausgebildeten Jedi-Ritter begleiten
und von diesem unterrichtet werden.
Die Padawane erhalten
während ihrer Ausbildung
ihr eigenes Lichtschwert.
Am Ende muss jeder Padawan
eine Prüfung bestehen,
um zum Jedi-Ritter
ernannt zu werden.
Auch die Jedi-Ritter können
einen höheren Rang erreichen,
den des Jedi-Meisters.
Dazu muss der Ritter
von einem Mitglied des hohen Rats
vorgeschlagen werden und noch
eine weitere Prüfung bestehen.
Und alle,
die immer noch nicht genug haben,
streben eine Platz im Hohen Rat an.
Dort sitzen die 12 weisesten
und mächtigsten Jedi-Meister.
Sie treffen
alle wichtigen Entscheidungen,
die im Jedi-Orden anfallen.
Jakob, danke
für die ausführliche Erklärung.
Neben mir steht jetzt jemand,
der schon oben im Rat sitzt.
Wahrscheinlich Deutschlands
mächtigster, weisester Jedi-Meister:
Hi.
Wie heißt du bürgerlich?
Das ist bisschen länger:
So geil, da ist der echte Name
komplizierter als der Jedi-Name.
Ja.
Max, schön dass du da bist.
Du darfst gleich
das Geheimnis lüften,
warum wir ausgerechnet
auf Burg Hessenstein sind.
Das war 2005, da wurde der Orden
aus einem Fanclub heraus gegründet.
Seither sind wir regelmäßig hier,
um die Jahrestreffen abzuhalten.
Hier werden eure Auszubildenden
zu Jedi-Rittern geschlagen.
Wir haben dank Jakob gesehen,
in dem Film ist es
ein langer, harter Weg hin zum Jedi.
Und evtl. auch zum Jedi-Meister.
Wie ist das bei euch?
Was muss ich genau machen,
um zum Jedi ausgebildet zu werden?
Wir haben uns
darüber Gedanken gemacht.
Denn wir orientieren uns
an der echten Welt.
Wir haben nicht die Vorstellung,
dass wir mit unseren Gedanken
Stühle rücken können.
Sondern was braucht ein Jedi
in der echten Welt.
Allgemeinbildung ist unabdingbar.
Denn wer weiß,
kann nicht veräppelt werden.
Diplomatie im Umgang
mit anderen Menschen ist wichtig.
Erweiterung des Geistes,
um zu verstehen, wie tickt
der andere neben mir und warum.
Selbstreflexion,
das bessere Ergebnis dessen zu sein,
was man am Tag vorher war.
Körperliche Ertüchtigung,
klar, gut für die Gesundheit.
Kreativität
ist nicht nur Kunst und Malen.
Sondern auch kreatives Denken,
wie löse ich ein Problem.
Ist das auch wie im Film, dass
man einen Meister zugeteilt bekommt?
Das haben wir vom Film übernommen.
Wichtig ist,
das ist ähnlich wie im Film,
dass es keine
autokratische Beziehung ist.
Dass der Meister sagt, du tust,
und er macht.
Sondern man lernt auch voneinander.
Wenn wir gut ausgebildet sind,
Spaß dabei haben
und als Gruppe zusammenkommen:
Wie wird man dann
zum Jedi-Ritter geschlagen?
Da gibt es sicher ein Ritual?
Wie funktioniert das?
Es gibt eine Zeremonie.
Aber man muss
vorher bereit dazu sein.
Denn Jedi-Ritter ist nicht nur, ich
kann mit dem Lichtschwert fuchteln
und sehe toll aus in einer Robe.
Sondern das ist
ein geistiger Reifungsprozess.
Das ist bei Menschen
unterschiedlich,
wie lange das dauert.
Der eine schafft das in 3 Jahren,
der andere in 10 Jahren.
Jeder hat sein Tempo.
Dann wirst du hier auf der Burg,
oder wo wir uns treffen,
vom Jedi-Rat zum Ritter geschlagen.
Das ist ein persönlicher Moment.
Wenn der Meister
und der Padawan ein Gespann werden,
gibt man sich gegenseitig
ein persönliches Versprechen,
dem anderen zu helfen.
Darum ist es eine Zeremonie,
die immer tief an die Herzen geht.
Auch von denen,
die drum herum sitzen.
Auch bei euch ist das also eine
intensive, jahrelange Ausbildung.
Ähnlich,
wie es im Film dargestellt ist.
Apropos Jedi-Meister.
Bald kommt die neue Kenobi-Serie.
Freut ihr euch schon drauf?
Was denkt ihr,
was wir über Obi-Wan erfahren werden?
Schreibt es in die Kommentare.
Ich habe mitgekriegt,
dass euch das viel bedeutet.
Dass ihr viel Zeit und Kraft
in eine persönliche
Weiterentwicklung investiert
und da emotionale Erlebnisse habt.
Wie weit spielt Religion
eine Rolle für euch,
also der Glaube an etwas Höheres?
Es gibt den Jediismus.
Und es gibt das Jeditum.
Das sind 2 verschiedene Dinge.
Ich habe bewusst mein Augenmerk
auf das Jeditum gelegt.
Weil das die philosophische
Komponente bei der Sache ist.
Und für den europäischen Raum,
für unsere kulturellen
Breitengrade ist es so,
dass die Religionen einen
gewissen Exklusiv-Anspruch haben.
Wenn du Christ bist, kannst du nicht
gleichzeitig Jude oder Muslim sein,
sondern du musst dich
für eins entscheiden.
Bei uns kannst du
in den Orden eintreten
und die Philosophie leben.
Auch als Jude oder Muslim,
das ist egal.
Was den Glauben
an die Macht angeht:
Es gibt das Zitat
von Obi-Wan Kenobi aus Episode IV:
*Er spricht auf Englisch.*
Das ist Tatsache, nicht nur
im glaubenstechnischen Bereich
von Dingen,
die man nicht versteht.
Auch in der Quantenphysik
ist alles miteinander verbunden.
In der Schule wurde gesagt,
das Universum
verliert nichts an Energie.
Das ist alles in einem Netz
miteinander verbunden.
Das können wir nicht sehen
und uns längst nicht erklären.
Das ist vorhanden,
auch das Suchen nach einer Antwort.
Und Wissen in diese Richtung,
aber philosophisch.
Ihr gebt euch nach außen hin
deutlich zu erkennen als Jedi.
Ihr identifiziert euch damit.
Wie ist da die Grenze zum Cosplay,
wenn man da provokant fragen möchte.
Ich will mich nicht
zu 1.000% vom Cosplay abgrenzen.
Einfach weil wir
daraus entstanden sind.
Ohne das Cosplay hätte ich
die Idee zu dem Orden nie gehabt.
Dazu kommt, wir tragen diese Roben.
Das, was ich jetzt anhabe,
ist ja kein Kostüm.
Sondern das ist
eine Zeremonien-Robe.
Das hier nicht,
das ist etwas lässig.
Aber wir tragen Roben
und keine Kostüme.
Das ist der größte Unterschied
zum Cosplay.
Ihr arbeitet mit dem Thema
inhaltlich weiter.
Du hast gesagt,
dass sich euer Kodex unterscheidet
vom Jedi-Kodex aus den Filmen.
Ja, ich finde, in einem
ganz entscheidenden Punkt.
Im Film-Kodex heißt es,
es gibt keine Gefühle.
Es gibt Frieden.
Die meisten Menschen, die das lesen,
werden denken, so ein Quatsch,
von wegen, es gibt keine Gefühle,
natürlich gibt es die.
Selbst Hunger ist ein Gefühl.
Wir haben daraus gemacht,
es gibt Gefühle, darum übe Frieden.
Aus dem Grund heraus,
weil Gefühle sehr stark sind.
D.h., in einem emotionalen Gespräch
kann es dir passieren,
dass ein Gefühl
einen rationalen Gedanken überfährt.
Dadurch geht das Gespräch
den Berg runter.
Wenn man das aber geübt hat und das
Gefühl sollte mich nicht überfahren,
weil das Gespräch sonst platzt:
Dann ist es besser,
als wenn man sagt,
es gibt keine Gefühle.
Dann ist das Gespräch
auch nicht gerettet.
Ich muss mir bewusst sein,
es gibt ein Gefühl,
wie gehe ich damit um.
Provokant gefragt:
Diese Art und Weise
der deeskalierenden Gesprächsführung
oder der Mitmenschlichkeit:
Das kriegt man evtl. auch so hin,
da gibt es auch andere Philosophien.
Warum braucht ihr jetzt das Jeditum?
Brauchen tun wir es nicht.
Aber für mich und für die Leute
in unserem Orden ist es so:
Dass man über diesen
fantasievollen, großen Gedanken
die Dinge, die uns umgeben,
etwas besser fassen kann.
Weil es gibt viele Sachen,
die man nicht gleich begreifen kann.
Für mich geht es noch viel weiter.
Ich bin Künstler, ich bin Sänger
und lebe nach dem Gedanken
des Schönen, Guten und Wahren.
"Star Wars" ist eine
sehr kreative Fantasie-Geschichte.
Das Gefühl kühlt den Geist.
Das hilft auch beim Lernen,
das hilft bei allem,
was wir in diesem Orden machen.
Wir nehmen uns auch nicht zu ernst,
weil sonst wäre alles vorbei.
Deswegen braucht es
für mich das Jeditum.
Und für manch andere auch.
Max, danke für die ganzen Einblicke,
die du mir gegeben hast.
Eine Frage habe ich noch.
Die betrifft die Keuschheit.
Wie sieht es da bei euch aus?
Haltet ihr euch an die Filmregeln?
Das ist ein völliger Quatsch,
denn Menschen haben Gefühle.
Wir leben von Gemeinschaft.
Wir leben auch von Liebe.
Natürlich darfst du
auch Kinder haben.
Klar, das ist bei uns
überhaupt kein Ding.
Das Einzige, was nicht erlaubt ist,
auch bei uns im Orden nicht,
ist eine Beziehung
zwischen Meister und Padawan.
Weil das
ein Verantwortungsverhältnis ist.
Das wäre problematisch.
Das kann ich verstehen.
Aber zumindest aufatmen für alle
Jedi-Anwärterinnen und -Anwärter,
die noch kleine Lukes
und Leias produzieren wollen.
Die Ausbildung zum Jedi ist nicht nur
in dem Film kein Zuckerschlecken.
Auch im echten Leben
muss man viel Willen,
Selbstbeherrschung
und Gehirnschmalz mitbringen.
Um den ehrwürdigen Rang
eines Jedi zu erlangen.
Wenn ihr Lust bekommen habt,
euch zum Jedi ausbilden zu lassen,
dann schaut in die Info-Box.
Da findet ihr einen Link
zum "Order of Jedi" von Max.
Da stehen alle notwendigen Infos.
Max, danke fürs Erklären.
Christian, danke
für deinen wissenschaftlichen Input.
Danke an Jakob
vom Kanal "Star Wars Stories".
Den Link zu ihm
packe ich unten mit rein.
Wenn ihr die Burg Hessenstein
besuchen wollt, macht das.
Es ist schön hier.
Ich freue mich,
wenn ihr einen Kommentar dalasst.
Aber vergesst nicht,
diesen Kanal zu ...
... abonnieren.
Und:
# Auf die Glocke zu hauen.
Dann können wir uns bald wiedersehen,
ich freue mich darauf.
Möge die Macht mit euch sein.
Nun, ich spüre große Lust bei euch.
Hier oben müsst ihr klicken.
Für Lord Vaders Anzug.
Und hier unten findet ihr
den Pfad zu Jakobs Seite.
Ihr müsst oben oder unten klicken.
Copyright MDR 2022